Maybe you did like a boron character
where you're, can you do German accent?
Not Arnold Schwarzenegger. Uh,
that's Austrian. Oh, okay. Yeah.
Um, no, I don't think I
could probably do one,
but Arnold so easy.
It's so like I can only do sir.
I can't do Trump, man. You can't
do trout. No, I can't do it at all.
My voice doesn't make those.
Sounds like I'm not a good impressionist.
I'm just good at the ones that I can do.
What does Arnold think? A Trump busy.
We've had this conversation before is
not a bad guy. He's just a guy. Oh,
that's right. He's, he's listening.
He's doing what everybody
wants is making billions.
These fucking porn stars
and you're mad at him.
This is the fucking American team
who looks like for real though,
who looks like him and fucks like he does.
I,
I'm a little bit more impressed
with Donald after all the
scandals. It backfired.
You guys. He's not, he's not
terminal Clinton on this guy.
He's not trying to fuck kids so that,
hey, you know, here's the thing about it,
like Roseanne Barr, they were
saying that Roseanne Barr was, uh,
theories that have been disproven.
This is what some thing,
cause she was talking about Trump,
break it up, child sex rings.
But he really did spend a lot of time
concentrating on that and having people go
out and try to break up these
sex rings and sex trafficking.
Like this is not something
that is a conspiracy theory.
This is something that
he's discussed many times.
It's also not a conspiracy
that there's sex trafficking.
So as much as you want to discount Trump,
here's a problem that I have with
people that are on the left right now.
They do not looking at everything,
throwing and looking at what they want
to look at. He's bad for the environment.
He's always lying. He cheats on his
wife, he does this, he does that.
They say all these things that he
does bad. But when something comes up,
like Roseanne says,
ah,
I'm giving him the benefit of the doubt
because he's going after sex trafficking.
And then it turns out all these other
people. So that's conspiracy theory.
That's a bullshit online. No, he
said it. He's put effort into it.
Like you got to give the guy credit
because if you don't give them credit for
things that he does that are important,
nobody's going to listen to
you when you're criticizing
them either because you,
all you're trying to do is when you're
not trying to look at the thing for what
it really is. Yeah. He's this
guy and he's not perfect person,
but he did make note on many
times about wanting to break up.
Seth just sex trafficking rings.
Do you know that you're, uh,
your kid is 20,000 times more likely
to get kidnapped them to get shot or to
school. Does that make sense?
Yeah. At 20,000 it's conservative.
It's probably really like 70,000
because if you go by the numbers,
800,000 to a million kids go missing
every year in the United States.
And I looked that up though. That doesn't,
I've never found a source for that.
You said that before and that it
wasn't nearly as I read it online,
so it could be wrong cause a problem
with these things, like when we say them,
especially if you say it,
I'm like right now 2 million people
are going to listen to us or whatever.
The fucking knows.
Even if it's 100,000 or
a hundred kids, that's more than
school shirts. That's my point.
It's more than school shootings.
Like what would you rather have your,
you know what's worse?
I don't know what's worse.
Get having your kid get shot at
school. Any, right. We'll get this.
According to the National Center
for missing exploited children,
citing US Department of Justice report,
nearly 800,000 children are
reported missing each year.
That's more than 2000 a day.
The end.
See Mec says 203,000 children are
kidnapped each year by family members.
Oh, family. Okay. Now take us a
little bit at least 600,000 yeah,
that'd be 600,000 so what's worse?
How does grace having your kid.